the Sierra Nevada it's Spanish for snowy
mountain range and the mountains are
home to a ski resort of the same name
winter sports in Andalusia our unusual
treat the city of Granada with its
Moorish Citadel the Alhambra is just a
stone's throw away the moors of old were
fascinated by the sierra nevada the ski
resort is just an hour away and the
views of magnificent the village of
prada yano at an altitude of 2,000
meters is a perfect place to stay before
heading up to the slopes raquel render
is waiting for us at the mid station at
borah gilles a professional ski
instructor she's known this here in
Nevada almost all her life she grew up
in these mountains again sobretodo
special about the Sierra Nevada is the
weather but of course we sometimes have
bad weather we have to have snow but
it's often a sunny and in spring we have
lots of good weather yes they promoted
on when we went on we take the lift to
the highest accessible point just below
the summit of Mount valletta 3,300
meters above sea level and it's going on
it's a lovely here the vastness the
tranquility and the sky is always so
clear on one hand everything so big and
on the other it's so small it's hard to
describe they're not says Bradley's plug
on the highest point in Europe
southernmost ski resort offers another
Vista as well a panorama overlooking the
Mediterranean
look I get to stand here 3,300 meters up
and look down at the sea is marvelous
you wouldn't get that in the Alps they
have other things but this is special is
there is no other this is our crown
jewel enough sightseeing now it's time
to ski all told 115 different pests
offer a hundred and two kilometers of
enjoyment for skiers and snowboarders
with runs for beginners to advanced
slopes since this past winter you can
even ski through a tunnel there are 22
lifts for winter sports enthusiasts in
this small but distinctive ski area
and for a change of pace there are other
activities as well like paragliding you
can also take off at the Salerno Park
the arena here is set to become a center
for freestyle snowboarding and it
doesn't offer just innovative ramps and
obstacles there's also internet access
this is an area where we even have Wi-Fi
we'd be so you can have fun film the
jumps and pirouettes and send them off
right away no voy hacia la vendo puedes
enviar en ese mismo momento every ski
resort has places to sit and eat
outdoors and Sierra Nevada is no
exception the only difference to the
Alps is that instead of dumplings you
get tortillas okay we see the other ones
I've been in many ski regions and I'd
liked many of them but my Granada my
mountains and my Beach simply can't be
built a key day if you don't want to
drive an hour and a half to the beach
you can find warmth and water 2000
meters up a spa with a glass pyramid
boasts a swim pool complete with
panoramic views
and then there's the designer hotel like
the resort itself the choice is fairly
limited but very appealing and after a
day of activity there's nothing as
delightful as watching the sunset over
the Sierra Nevada